موجز الاخبار من الجزيره السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله افاد مراسل الجزيره في السودان
باستخدام الصحه ثقيله في اشتباكات بين
قوات الجيش وقوات دعم السريع قرب من طاقه
الصناعيه وحيي الرميله والحله الجديده غرب
الخرطوم كما سمع دوي انفجارات في ام درمان
وشهد تصاعد لاعمده الدخان وتحليق للطائرات
الحربيه في سماء مدن الخرطوم الثلاث
وفي قمه ايجاده التي عقدت في جيبوتي قال
الرئيس الكنينه توصلت الى مبادرة لحل
الازمه في السودان تشمل وقفا لاطلاق النار
وفتح ممرات امنه واداره حوار بين قوى
مدنيه
وقد حذر رئيس فوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي من
حرب اهليه في السودان اذا لم يتوقف القتال
وقال ان الاوضاع التي تتفاقم في السودان
تهدد المنطقه باكملها
من جانبه قال مالك عقار نائب رئيس مجلس
سياده السوداني للجزيره الى هيئه لايجاد
اقترحت لقاء بين البرهان وحماتي خلال
اسبوعين ولم يحدد عقار مكان اللقاء
نقل موقع واكسوس عن مسؤولين اسرائيليين
وامريكيين ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه ابلغت
اداره انها تعتزم لاعلان هذا الشهر عن
بناء وتخطيط الاف الوحدات السكنيه الجديده
في المستوطنات بالضفه الغربيه المحتله
وعاشر الموقع الى ان ادارتها تضغط على
الحكومه الاسرائيليه لثنيها عن هذه الخطوه
من جانبه طلب رئيس الوزراء الفلسطيني بضغط
دولي حقيقي لمنع تقسيم الضفه الغربيه عبر
مخطط اي واحده لاستيطاني
اعلنا الجيش الاوكراني استعادتها بلدات
جديده في الجبهات الشرقيه والجنوبيه واكد
انه خضع اكثر من 20 معركه في الساعات
الماضيه في المقابل اعلنا الجيش الروسي
تصديه لهجمات القوات الاوكرانيه ابرزها
وفي جنوبي دوناتسك
من جاته قال الرئيس الاوكرانين قوه بلاده
تتقدم في الهجوم المضاد رغم ضراوه المعارك
مشيرا الى ان خسائر العدو تتطابق مع الخطط
الاوكرانيه
الى ذلك اعرب وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه عن
امله في اجبار الرئيس الروسي على التفاوض
اذا نجح الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
وفي باريس عقدت قمه فرنسيه المانيه
بولنديه لبحث تقديم المساعده العسكريه
والانسانيه لاوكرانيا
اعلن الامين العام للامم المتحده ان
التحضيرات العلماء تؤكد ان مخاطر الذكاء
الاصطناعي لا تقل خطوره عن الحروب النوويه
وطلب المجتمع الدولي باخذ هذه التحذيرات
على محمليا الجد
وقلم ان اتجاه واشنطن للعوده الى منظمه
اليونسكو يهدف الى منع الصين من الاستئثار
بوضع معايير عالميه لسياسات استخدام
الذكاء الاصطناعي انتهى الموجه لما كنتم
طبت اوقاتكم بكل خير